- It's Halloween in a few days.
- Yes.
- So, did your kids
like to trick or treat?
Did you like taking 'em?
I love taking mine.
- To be honest.
Yes, but to be honest,
Halloween is not a big
holiday for me or my wife.
- Okay.
- We, we never,
we- you know, a day that
celebrates everything
that you would not want
to see in a nightmare is,
is, you know, I never quite got it.
And so we never went to
any Halloween parties.
We never, we never,
you know, put on costumes
to go to a Halloween party.
- Y'all never even went to mine.
- I-, what was that?
- You never went to mine.
I love Halloween parties.
- Well I make a living
putting on costumes.
( Kelly Clarkson laughing)
(audience laughing)
The last thing I want
to do in my spare time,
is really put on a costume.
But when I had kids,
that all kind of changed,
cause you get the same
kind of excitement that,
- Yes.
- you actually had for Halloween,
- Oh My Gosh.
- when you're a kid. Oh.
- They're so cute and little.
- Oh my!
(Kenny Clarkson giggling)
Well, when Daniel was,
Daniel known as Dan Levy
to the rest of the world,
but when Daniel was maybe three,
we, we, he went on his first Halloween.
- Yeah.
- And my wife made him the
best Halloween costume.
He was a chef and it was very simple,
but we put a white apron on him
that he tied and she
made a great chef's hat.
- What? She made it? Okay.
- She, ya, she made it,
she made the band and the
little puffy thing on top
and it kind of sat on his head
( Kenny Clarkson giggling)
and I drew a little,
- Oh he was a French
- mustache. Right.
And he, and he went out
with a- holding a wooden spoon.
And he went out as, Chef Pierre.
- Chef Piel.
- Yes, the cutest little thing.
- I love it.
- And, and my daughter's first costume
was, was a kind of a princess costume
that we, we bought.
We didn't make it, but she put it on.
She had the tiara, she
had the sparkly wand.
- Ya, did she light up?
- She lit up.
- Aww.
- You couldn't get the grin off her face.
- I love that, that-
- You couldn't get the grin off her.
- my daughter, the first
one was princess as well.
She felt so beautiful.
- Because she actually felt
like she was a princess.
- Yes, and you couldn't
convince mine otherwise either.
- Yeah.
- Yes. I love that.